et
[Musique]
par qui pour exterminer gégène la
première expédition shadow qui a été
décimée gégène amis les shadoks note au
garde-manger les shadoks notes n'étaient
pas revenus
mais les shadoks n'était pas inquiet
pour autant
et même ils commençaient à crier
victoire parce que disait-il
ce n'est pas parce que les shadoks notre
ne revenait pas que ça prouvé qu'il
n'avait pas gagné
il suffisait d'envoyer d'autres purent
aller se renseigner
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ainsi partie la seconde expédition
mais si d'ici là ne revint pas non plus
elisha duke ne furent pas plus
renseignés alors il fallut tout envoyer
2 puis d'autres puits dont etc
vous vous doutez bien que toutes ces
malheureux expédition la finissait comme
la première dans le garde-manger de
geiger il coule elle a des jours heureux
en se racontant leurs exploits en
attendant que gégène éléments et plus ça
allait plus de garde-manger s'emplissait
est plus là ne se désemplit c'est alors
les shadoks se mirent à douter le moral
baissait on murmurait la révolte et le
devin plombier subitement eu une idée
puisque on ne pouvait pas vaincre gégène
on lui faisons la guerre nous le
vaincrons il disait en lui faisons la
paix son plan était simple
premièrement faire la paix avec gégène
en lui jouant de la musique
deuxièmement l'exterminer à l'aide de
l'exterminateur
c'est à apprendre la musique aux shadoks
nôtre
[Musique]